hey what's going on it's Bill Burr it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday November 14
2022. what's going on how are you uh
Sunday night in my house I just put both
my kids to bed
uh my wife is out of town so I'm running
I'm running the [ __ ] show
all right I'm making the calls
I decide who's gonna have [ __ ]
granola or if they're eating pancakes so
if they're a healthy pancakes or the
[ __ ] other ones I'm making all the
calls
still [ __ ] getting over being sick or
whatever I [ __ ] hate being sick
there's always that dose who says that
I'm sick I [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate being
sick oh yeah well yeah everybody does
what are you thinking Some people enjoy
it I'll actually tell you there is an
aspect of being sick that I like
it's called clearing your schedule
you know
I should [ __ ] save
I should record myself
right now you know here's what you do
here's what you do
um yeah when you're in this mode
record yourself going yeah hey it's me
uh I'm [ __ ] sick man I can't make it
in you know that cough I just it would
have been great you can steal that cough
if you want to make it yours can't make
it in today blah blah blah you just save
them
for when you want a fake sick and just
clear your [ __ ] schedule
so I got to be honest with you uh if I
wasn't sick laying in bed for like three
days was kind of [ __ ] awesome
you know and just being like
I don't know like
gee I'd love to pitch in and be a viable
member of this [ __ ] family but I'm
not I'm not feeling well
my wife was all just like you need to
stay in bed and you need to drink liquor
liquids right she's like here drink this
and she kept coming with medicine I'm
like what what is that
what are you what are you [ __ ] Dr
Joyce Brothers over there like when did
you get a medical degree she came in
with all this [ __ ]
and she gave it to me and she was like
accusing me of not drinking it
pretending to drink it like I was in One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest and I was
like I drank it
it's gross
you know tastes like medicine
oh [ __ ] so
anyway I'm gonna do as long as I can on
this podcast all right I'm just gonna do
the best I can
all right and then expect full credit
you know
sorry I'm trying to relate
to what I see out there
um sorry
anyway
uh
uh where should we start
let's start let's start at the beginning
here
um sad sad news legendary stand-up
comedian Gallagher passed away
um on Friday I believe November 11th man
Jesus Christ
and deserved way more of a send-off
than he got you know
um that [ __ ] guy
was so huge
to so many comedians of my generation I
mean he was like so ridiculously
prolific the guy had like an HBO special
every year for like
a
decade
and he was a fascinating comedian in
that
he existed
somewhere between George Carlin
and Carrot Top
he kind of ran this whole gamut both of
whom I find hilarious for different
reasons
like I never gave into that you know I
maybe early on my stand-up career when I
was insecure and I would listen to other
comedians talk about what real stand-up
comedy was
that guy's a guitar that guy just does
Impressions this person you know does
too much crowd work this person does
props you know that I I just find I was
just like all right let's press it and
they move around too much
like it got it got so [ __ ] snobby
when I started that it's like if you
[ __ ] move too much
it was all he just goes up there he just
stands there and I keep saying he
because it was mostly guys doing it
you know
it was like
you know women before World War II like
none of them had [ __ ] jobs
as far as I don't know
maybe a documentary I kind of saw I
don't know it was mostly guys
so like the guys that got the most
respect were the guys that could go on
[ __ ] stage like walk up to the
microphone he doesn't even take the
microphone out of the [ __ ] stand man
and they would just stand there
and just what they wrote they would
recite and they could kill
which admittedly was amazing
but what I loved about Gallagher was he
had all of these
you know
it was a fascinating guy he had all of
this really deep [ __ ] that he was
talking about
but then he had all this silly stuff
like coming out in a giant bicycle or
sitting on that big couch and of course
in the end
smashing the Watermelons and when I was
a kid
I didn't really get that bit I just
thought it was funny that this guy had a
giant hammer was smashing all this [ __ ]
that was going into the crowd
I didn't get that he was making fun of
advertising
and was sort of commenting on
these stupid commercials that were
selling you something completely [ __ ]
useless
that you didn't even need and that was
not going to make your life more simple
and he was sort of making fun of that by
just coming up with the stupidest thing
ever this ledgermatic
which basically smashed everything right
but then he had all of these like these
incredible bits like he had this one bit
where he was talking about the English
language and he sat down at a school
desk I remember that
and he started off
whatever word he started with
led to another word which led to another
word and led to another word and he did
this whole long bit and it went all the
way back to the to the word that he
started with
and I just remembered like
you know he was talking about the
pronunciation of stuff
and um h-e-a-r-d heard and then he
pointed to his face he's like is this a
bird no beard okay beard b-e-a-r-d and
then he would connect it that way he sat
at a school desk and he went all the way
around in a circle it was a really
[ __ ] smart bit
and um
you know we had themes to him I had one
you know when he was addressing the fact
that as we were losing all the
manufacturing in this country
he had this whole thing like what did
you do to uh you know beat Japan or
China today which nowadays would be
considered you know you couldn't say
[ __ ] like that but like
you know it was different back then it
was like teams you could just you know I
actually saw like
around that same era
you know
when Tom was sort of
great Tom Lasorda was managing the
Dodgers they went down to San Diego
and it was ever starting pitching that
day beamed one of the San Diego Padres
so some guy in the Padres mouth off he
goes I think that guy was went out there
and he was told to do it and I think it
goes back to that fat Italian
he said that about Tommy Lasorda that
fat Italian in the newspapers you could
never do that today
so to put it in his you know in
perspective like that's the way he was
doing [ __ ] right
um
anyway and I know he got a little nuts
in the end or whatever
um
but like that period in the 80s and the
comedy that that guy did and the
specials that he put out
and the thought behind all of it
um
I I just I [ __ ] I just I couldn't wait I
couldn't wait to watch him I [ __ ]
loved every single one of them
and um
and I remember as I was coming up you
know I would play a club in Gallagher
had been there the week before and
there'd be you know still stuff in the
ceiling and [ __ ] like that
and um I always thought I was gonna meet
him I never met the guy
bummed out about that but I do want to
say
you know
thank you to him
for all of those great specials
and
um
I don't know he just just amazing body
of work that he did
and um
I felt he deserved more of a send-off
than he got
um all right
so with that
I don't know if my Bruins won today I
watched the first period when my kids
were
screaming at me my son wanted to watch
he's like garbage truck gosh Chuck tada
guys Chuck
and you know what's funny is the video
that I watch has like this [ __ ]
GarageBand like
sort of speed metal like you know late
80s early 90s it goes like
Jacobs
my son starts like when he comes on he
starts like banging his head to it
um and it's really kind of the perfect
um music you know
playing metal music is this big metal
truck comes up the street
um
so we were watching that [ __ ]
and then my daughter likes watching
[ __ ]
Super Mario where they're like
you're watching I don't know who's
playing the video game I don't
understand what's going on but she sits
there rooting for Super Mario and I root
for Luigi
so I basically I saw the first period
or I want to say was it was it two to
one yeah it was two to one
like Vancouver got the first one but I
watched the whole Buffalo game
and Jesus Christ I mean look it looked
like a friendly both Buffalo and the
Bruins came out and I don't think I saw
a check for the first two [ __ ]
periods they were just skating around
and uh I'm like of course I finally have
time to watch it like they're like 12
and 2 or whatever or eleven and two or
something I'm finally gonna get a chance
to watch the whole game
hang with my father-in-law he's in town
so we want to watch the game and um
I'm gonna watch they're gonna [ __ ]
loses so it was one to nothing towards
the end of the second period I said to
my father-in-law I said whoever score is
next going to win this game this is one
of these games
Buffalo scores next the Bruins are just
going to stay asleep this whole [ __ ]
game
Bruins score next they're going to
[ __ ] wake up and they're going to put
these guys to bed and that's what
happened Bergeron scored
and then they went into third period
carried the thing
carried the momentum but what kept us in
the game was this kid Keith Kincaid
which I think is a Third String Goalie
Keith Rubin Kincaid stood on his [ __ ]
head
for three periods incredible goddamn
saves we ended up winning uh three to
one
um
I don't know dude we're uh moving along
here
we're crushing it it's only November so
you know
just hoping we stay healthy and I don't
know I don't know how you keep this pace
up but it's been [ __ ] awesome
to uh to be reading about hearing about
and actually sitting down watching a
little bit but here here's where I start
to [ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] quietly
the kids are asleep down the hall here
um
once again guys let's talk the prevent
defense
one of the wildest football games I've
seen in a long time
all right the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
versus the Seattle Seahawks don't [ __ ]
with you the Bills versus the Vikings
the Bills versus the Vikings
okay so I'm watching the Bills game
and
you know Vikings score first go up Seven
to nothing and then it was just all
bills
right up until the half okay and there
was just something about in the third
[ __ ] quarter
I because I picked the bills to win it
all
and I was saying like you know I don't
know what it is about Buffalo man they
just
they seem beatable
it doesn't make any sense but they do
they got all they got major [ __ ]
talent and all the [ __ ]
you know sexy positions right
the ones that you know get all the
[ __ ] looks on SportsCenter but
there's something about them in November
they just still feel a little loose I
don't know what it is and they're
[ __ ] letting the goddamn Vikings hang
around and they're doing dumb [ __ ] like
going for it on Fourth and goal
and like the third quarter and [ __ ] it's
like kick the [ __ ] field goal take
the points take the [ __ ] points
you're letting these guys [ __ ] hang
around they never talk about that [ __ ]
and I don't get these coaches they got
all the [ __ ] balls in the world
for the first [ __ ] 58 minutes of the
game
going forward on Fourth and down fourth
and [ __ ] whatever in the first
[ __ ] quarter then the end of the game
they [ __ ] I don't know what they get
neutered
sorry I'm gonna lose my [ __ ] voice on
this one so
basically what happens
is the Vikings are down
what that was 27
23
they're all the way down in the [ __ ]
one yard line
they go for it on fourth down they don't
get it
but there's a penalty
offsides the guy almost timed the snap
perfectly
on the bills he got a great jump just a
half a second too early
so then they they [ __ ]
they get another one so it's like okay
obviously now they're gonna [ __ ]
score
um
they hand it off and they don't score
and the bills [ __ ] stop them and
they're on like this the [ __ ] half
yard line
so Josh Allen can't take a knee
I guess he could have ran out the back
of the end zone
you know and taking the safety but then
they're just going to play the prevent
they're just going to come right down
the [ __ ] and then it would have been
27-25 yeah and there's way too much time
left in the game why because people go
into a [ __ ] prevent defense
so anyway so they hiked the ball
and Al Josh Allen's just going to do
like basically quarterback sneak get
himself enough [ __ ] room where he can
just down the thing and the game's gonna
be over
they have a fumbled snap it's literally
like the miracle in the Meadowlands
except they didn't have to run it they
just land on the [ __ ] ball
and the Vikings get a [ __ ] touchdown
they're stunned in Buffalo
all right
that makes it 30 to 27.
okay and in defense of people who say go
forward and fourth down
the Vikings on their last touchdown on
the extra point the guy [ __ ] did miss
it that does happen Okay but it happens
way [ __ ] less you make way more field
goals than you make on fourth down going
forward I feel
so
anyway
like people aren't like pissed if you
don't make it in fourth and goal you
miss a field goal next to point they're
like what the [ __ ]
you're supposed to that's the level of
percentage I feel so anyway
so the Vikings score there's like 50
seconds left 52 seconds left
all right
and for whatever [ __ ] reason the
Vikings go into this prevent defense
like I've never seen
the second that like 15 yards off the
[ __ ] line of scrimmage
they hike the ball to Josh Allen
immediately everybody on defense that
isn't rushing disappears out the right
side of my [ __ ] television Josh Allen
throws one to the right side I'm just by
memory here
okay they get 12 yards and the guy gets
out of bounds it took five seconds
now considering it's all about analytics
by the way they started on like the 25
yard line or some [ __ ] like that so now
they're all the way up to like the
[ __ ] 37 or something
they just got five yards and got out of
bounds you game a free [ __ ] time up
all right I did that in five seconds so
now there's like 47 seconds left
and if it's all about math
okay if they're going to get 12 yards
every five seconds and there's 50
seconds left to start the [ __ ] thing
in four plays these guys are gonna go 48
[ __ ] yards and they're down by three
points
they continue to play this [ __ ] thing
and can you believe it
Josh Allen he throws like four or five
completions in a row to the point the
[ __ ] ball
in less than half a [ __ ] minute is
down on their goddamn 25 they got down
there so [ __ ] fast they actually had
a shot they they could they could waste
One play to the end zone to possibly win
the [ __ ] game you play to win the
games right
it doesn't work out and then it's a
[ __ ] Chip Shot and now they go into
overtime
all right Vikings ended up going in
kicking a field goal bills came down
they go to kick a field goal I think
they make the um
the uh my
my feet out here switched over to the
Rams game so I couldn't see it [ __ ]
[ __ ] so
bills I think Mr field goal or something
like that but my point is why didn't you
just play defense
is my question in that situation they
act like
the entire game when they're playing
defense every other Drive some wide
receiver gets behind their safety and
catches a 70-yard bomb
that doesn't even happen every game
I mean it happens but it doesn't happen
every [ __ ] game so I I don't somebody
I keep asking this question you can't
tell me there's not a football coach out
there listen to this [ __ ] thing
what is like I thought the initial thing
on the prevent defense was
you gave up the middle of the field
you kept them in bounds and you just ate
up the clock
now they don't even do that they just
give them 20 yards
and let them run out of bounds so it's
like we're going to give you 12 yards
every five seconds and a free time out
um I don't know I'm gonna start calling
it the Make-A-Wish defense
you know because that's what it looks
like you know you ever see like
when one of those poor kids is sick or
something like that and they let them
play with the professional players they
run around they act like ah we can't
tackle you or whatever
to make somebody's dream come true that
big heartwarming moment yeah they
actually do that in games too
I guess to keep the other head coach
from losing his [ __ ] job
I don't know can somebody please explain
like I'm just you know I know I go on
[ __ ] and then I won't shut up about it
um but this is my latest thing okay
I'm over the Astros congratulations you
finally won a World Series without
cheating your [ __ ] asses off to the
point you lost 10 draft picks your
pieces of [ __ ]
all right
and for whatever [ __ ] reason it's
still gonna be they have two World
Series Championships
um so I'm past that
um
Violet just is like a gambler to just be
watching that I actually I'm doing all
right so far I'm two and one this week
because now I'm starting to factor in
the prevent defense and if I think the
other team even remotely has a chance at
keeping it close usually a division
rivalry I just factor in the [ __ ]
the prevent defense and I just don't
know how Vegas can be that good that
they can figure out
whether it's going to be a field goal or
a touchdown I just smell a [ __ ] rat
in this whole thing like it none of it
makes [ __ ] sense
all right or maybe it's what it usually
is is I'm oversimplifying this situation
but it just seems to me that when you go
into the prevent defense you're not
playing defense
the whole purpose of Defense
is to [ __ ] prevent the other team
from scoring
and the second you go into a prevent
defense you're conceding points
um
I mean how many times you got to [ __ ]
see that [ __ ] sorry I gotta hang on a
second
like if the other team is up by seven
points
and there's like a minute left
you automatically know
the other team's going to go into a
prevent defense and the team with the
ball is going to go down the field in
five plays and then they're going to
have four shots at the end zone They
just concede that
they [ __ ] concede that and they don't
play defense until they start going for
the end zone and then all of a sudden
the game gets hard again
the whole time they were going down the
field when you could have made it
[ __ ] hard
you know they don't I just don't [ __ ]
okay Bill we get it you don't get it all
right cool all right fine
so anyway I made it through my 10 days
of detox
you know first 10 days of the month
that's my [ __ ] [ __ ] now every month
the first 10 days I don't [ __ ] do
anything
all right no soda no cigars no weed and
no coffee I was able to do everything
except the coffee
um
coffee is uh
definitely in my life but I only have in
one cup a day that's a lie I had [ __ ]
two yesterday but I you know I'm doing
the best I can here so now
it's the rest of the month and now I can
kind of do you know
lazily go back in if I decide to but
then like I'm sitting there going like
well why don't I keep going
you know and then all of a sudden I'll
be defense December 1st then I gotta
shut it off again and then I'll have
like a little streak going here
so
as far as all of my uh addictions
you know
soda's done
cigars are done I don't have any desire
to [ __ ] smoke one which is great
because I'm an old dad and I got kids so
I really need to look out for that [ __ ]
um
I went off my diet though because I got
[ __ ] sick this week and I started you
know
my wife was [ __ ] away and I was just
like uh you know you ever just
ReDiscover something in your kitchen
when you're sick like oh we got a
[ __ ]
panini press don't we
I don't feel good I'm gonna make a
grilled cheese sandwich right [ __ ]
crank one of those bad boys out
right can't have a grilled cheese
sandwich without something salty
and crunchy right so I did that and then
that just set me off the rails because I
was eating [ __ ] veggie I was doing
great
not playing like healthy [ __ ] so
whatever I had a bad [ __ ] week
today I made like a turkey [ __ ]
sandwich that I was like well you know
let's go Emerald lugassi here let's
[ __ ] kick it up a notch I just broke
out the panini
[Applause]
but for the most part I ate like uh
vegetarian I went a little bit for a
walk today but I was doing so [ __ ]
well man
uh but I'll get it back whatever I'll
[ __ ] get it back all right let me do
some of the reads here for this week and
I'm gonna [ __ ] hang
with this podcast for as long as I can
but I'm not gonna lie to my [ __ ]
voice is tired I got to do some golf
thing tomorrow too
I [ __ ] agreed you don't need
something [ __ ] funny
um
so we put together this [ __ ] charity
thing
where you could like you know
bid money to golf with a comedian or
some [ __ ]
so what whatever [ __ ] reason they put
me out there because I don't even golf
as you guys know right
so meet up buddy of mine are gonna golf
with these two people I don't even know
who they are
and um
I really don't want to [ __ ] go just
because I'm sick
you know but what's cool is if I wasn't
sick there's no [ __ ] way
I'm gonna go out there and play that
boring ass [ __ ] game
without smoking a giant cigar I mean
that's just what the [ __ ] I was gonna do
all right I'm out there for the cigar
you know and and I get the tunes going I
got a little Bose [ __ ] speaker thing
I put it in the golf cart you know we
listen to [ __ ] songs the whole time I
got my [ __ ] root beer I got my cigar
oh is it my turn to hit what did I get
in that hole I don't know let's say a
nine
[ __ ] gives a [ __ ] with you goddamn
stupid ass game
so
I gotta do that [ __ ] tomorrow so
hopefully uh
after a good night's sleep I'll [ __ ]
feel alright because I don't want to be
like if
I've never done one of these things but
it's weird it's like we're playing 18
holes so I kind of got to be like on
for 18 holes it's like a [ __ ] Dave
Chappelle set
you know Dave Dave can do stand-up for
like three hours
which by the way how great was he on SNL
um I can't do stand up for three hours
but now I'm [ __ ] golfing so now I
have to channel
Dave Chappelle
oh God I should have asked him for some
[ __ ] pointers so I got to do that no
I I'm [ __ ] with you it's going to be
a great time I'm just being a [ __ ]
because I'm [ __ ] sick
uh I'll get out there it'll be fine
and uh
we'll uh we'll move on from there
um all right let me uh oh here's
something else here's something else
that I was going to talk to you about
I'm not going to say any shows here
because I know how hard people work on
shows when they write and work and all
of that type of [ __ ]
all right so I'm not going to name the
shows but like my wife always gets into
these shows
these Series right and she's like why
don't you watch this series with me
and I try to watch him and I'm just
finding more and more
that these dramatic series
like you watch like three episodes and
you're like
okay like who am I supposed to be
rooting for here
like this kind there's nobody nobody's
like the hero anymore
it's just
15 to 20 people
that are just pieces of [ __ ] like
everybody's a piece of [ __ ] so then it's
like what what
am I supposed to get emotionally
invested that this piece of [ __ ]
did a piece of [ __ ] thing to this piece
of [ __ ] who did that piece of [ __ ] thing
to that other piece of [ __ ]
and
it's kind of like a thing that happens
is my wife hangs in there and I just
after three episodes I'll just be like
Nia I I don't give a [ __ ] about anybody
in this series
they're all just [ __ ] horrible people
like I so anyway she's on the road right
not on the road she's out on a wedding
right
he's doing some gigs oh God that would
be great she started doing the gigs and
I got to stay home and be [ __ ]
fantastic
drop the kids off at school I'd take a
cooking class I'll do that I'll be the
stay-at-home mom [ __ ] taking a
pilates class
um you know
and I'd enjoy it for three months and
then I'd [ __ ] resent her because she
gets to go out in the world
you know I do that that's a that's a my
wife doesn't do that [ __ ] but like
that's a big thing a lot of women do
you know they want to marry a guy
you know that makes enough money that if
they don't want to [ __ ] work
you know
they don't have to
I mean the [ __ ] balls of that
can you imagine that like just every day
you have a day off
and you're living in a [ __ ] house
and somebody else is at work paying for
it I mean that's just [ __ ] amazing
I only sit around they [ __ ]
and then like what ends up happening you
know I've seen this happen
is the woman she ends up getting bored
listen how do you know what my identity
is anymore yeah you do
you're that chick who [ __ ] sits
around the house all the time
you know you tried a couple of hobbies
and now you're [ __ ] bored
and then they end up getting mad at the
guy who's out there [ __ ] working his
way to an early grave you can't win
that was all vague there was no names
involved
for all you guys know I just made up
that scenario and said it's a common
thing that happens in relationships
um
no I think it happens with like uh
you know
maybe she's [ __ ] shows my wife is
watching
but it just always seems like there's
the rich guy and he's [ __ ] working
his ass off and then the wife's at home
totally taken care of but she's bored
and needs some excitement
so then she either tries to kill the guy
or she starts [ __ ] somebody else or
both
you know
wait a minute is my wife plotting
something okay
I miss when she's on this podcast
because she would have rolled with that
and talked about how she's been trying
to [ __ ]
anyway all right
let me um
let me read some of the
advertising
oh here we go fight camp
hey man are you looking for one of the
most exhilarating and effective forms of
Home Fitness
um
fight Camp brings the best workout in
the world into your home and makes it
fun explore thousands of workouts led by
expert trainers that meet you on your
time live punch stats motivate you to
push harder and help you map out your
progress knock out achievements or go
head-to-head against other Rivals from
across the country
or across the living room
wait I can fight some other fat dad
do I get a belt to hold up my [ __ ]
trunks learn the basics and sharpen your
skills over time through tailored paths
wait this isn't this [ __ ] where you have
that stupid mirror on the wall have you
seen that [ __ ] thing
this is the new thing in home fitness
and
they got a [ __ ] like a TV screen
except it's like vertical on the wall
and it's like everybody's trying to get
into that computer game
where it's just like oh it's obsolete
it's [ __ ] now now you can't do your
workouts you got to keep buying a new
one and all of those things are going to
end up in the [ __ ] ocean
you know it's like these dumb [ __ ] who
can't just go out and ride a bicycle
they gotta dress like they're in a
[ __ ] bike race or doing a time trial
I I just don't understand those the same
thing people they go to [ __ ] gym they
get a dress like a [ __ ] X-Man wearing
compression tights and [ __ ] like your
Allen Iverson
you know you go you're going on an
elliptical
[ __ ] are you doing it becomes a whole
fashion thing
dude when I used to go to the gym like
you [ __ ] everybody went there you look
like Rocky you had the gray hooded
sweatshirt and gray sweatpants and you
tucked the towel in around your neck
that's what the [ __ ] it did and you
gotta work out
well old man Billy's on his [ __ ] eye
horse all right they'll break down every
punch and ensure you use proper form so
you can learn to box safely fun not only
do these workouts maximize efficiency
with high intensity interval training
but they also they're also a really good
time before long you'll forget you're
even working out yeah and you can get
knocked out by some other fat dad and
not get CTE brain Fitness Boxing
requires Focus precise combinations push
you to think about every punch you throw
it's the ultimate way to clear your mind
and forget you're working out join the
biggest boxing community in the world
without leaving your home with fight
Camp you get started you can get started
with fight camp for as low as nine
dollars a month there you go
at fightcamp.com look at that how much
does a gym cost go to fightcamp.com to
learn more get started with fight camp
for as low as nine dollars a month at
fightcamp.com
all right butcher box everybody
this Black Friday
your search for amazing deals on high
quality protein ends with butcher box
yeah you know what's great you don't
have to get trampled at Walmart to be
with [ __ ] Butcher books
the only time you should get trampled
is if you're one of those [ __ ] idiots
that goes to a national park and gets
out of a car
to go get a selfie with a bison you know
what I mean there's no [ __ ] way as a
human being you should ever put yourself
in a position to get trampled to death
by other human beings okay
it's not [ __ ] worth it the second
there's too many people and you're
getting that feeling just walk away
everybody's filming it on their cell
phones anyway just I'm telling you all
right butcher box takes the guesswork
out of finding high quality Meat and
seafood you can trust 100 percent
grass-fed beef free range organic
chicken pork raise crate free and wild
caught
Seafood
not that [ __ ] hanging with the goddamn
maggots
in the labs
that's what I learned huh humanely
raised no antibiotics or added hormones
ultimate convenience yeah this meat is
is Barry Bonds on the Pirates not when
he was on the Giants ultimate
convenience get just what you want
delivered right to your doorstep free
shipping for the continental U.S and no
surprise fees incredible value enjoy a
range of high quality cuts that are hard
to come by at the grocery store it's an
amazing value I love butcher box this
Friday this Black Friday
butcherbox is offering our listeners one
of their best steak deals get two 10
ounce rib eyes free in every box for a
whole year
when you join
what
dude just take those things and throw
them in a freezer you're good for the
next three pandemics
plus an additional ten dollars off
okay you guys in the middle of those red
States if you're building a doomsday
[ __ ] thing and you already got your
guns you know how great would that be
when all the Liberals are running around
in their [ __ ] Priuses and you're
sitting underground with your AR-15s and
a bunch of [ __ ] 10 ounce rib eyes
I mean that's [ __ ] amazing
um
anyway that's free rib eyes wait sign up
today at butcherbox.com and use code
Burr b-u-r-r that's free rib eyes for a
year plus ten dollars off at
butcherbox.com with the code Burr
b-u-r-r
all right Roman Roman 52 of men over 40
experience some form of erectile
dysfunction in their life
well isn't there really one form
it's you trying to get erect while
someone else Waits patiently and it
doesn't happen
what is the other one
you know
the person you know you want to bang is
heckling your dick I don't understand
anyway if you're experiencing Ed
erectile dysfunction there's help Roman
is the digital health clinic for men
Roman offers genuine FDA approved
medication for as little as four dollars
per vote for per dose sorry at Roman
there are no waiting rooms and no
hassles man just a straightforward and
convenient digital experience which
means you can take care of it all from
the comfort of your home getting started
is simple just grab your laptop or
mobile device and start your free online
visit a U.S licensed health care
professional will work with you to find
the best treatment plan if medication is
appropriate Roman sends it right to your
door with free two-day shipping
everything arrives in discrete packaging
right now Roman has a special offer for
our listeners use this link to get 20
off your first order just go
to ro
um.com c-o slash Burr today that's
um Romeo Oscar dot Charlie Oscar slash
Burr for twenty percent off Amino Suites
okay oh sorry off of Rome Amino Suites
I didn't [ __ ] put this together right
that's at Roman
okay ro.co slash bird today Amino Suites
is something different this is people
writing and sorry
oh my God my [ __ ] head's killing me
here all right Amino Suites
dear bill
to Aid in your years long quest to
casually bring awareness to the problems
with the food industry I wanted to give
you an update oh this is pretty amazing
uh
as part
to me
aspartame the artificial sweetener that
is linked to numerous health problems
has been officially renamed
oh my God I can't wait for CNN and fox
to blow the lid off of this one huh
it's never going to happen
um
anyway uh
it's been officially renamed and the
fine folks at the FDA continue to have
our backs by letting them do so
yeah the FDA evidently was infiltrated
by people in these these uh
the Food and Drug businesses a long time
ago they just get their own guys in
there and they just approve [ __ ] that's
what I heard anyway the artificial
sweetener is now listed as Amino Suites
so this guy is saying to avoid this [ __ ]
I'm not sure how many documentaries they
need to make about this before people
stop thinking diet soda isn't making you
fat
yeah I stay with that [ __ ] fat free ice
cream diet soda it's like when we have a
soda I get the original I know it's
still [ __ ] for you but like I don't want
the one that's trying to be like
actually healthy
you know
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm saying
don't listen to me all right blue versus
red or maybe neither
hey Bill on Monday you were talking
about
the recent U.S presidential results and
asked whether a bunch of red people
thought Trump had it in the bag and
didn't show
up or did a bunch of blue people show up
who didn't in 2016. that's not what I
said
I didn't think I was talking about every
midterm election
it seems like if we just voted all blue
we run over to all red and then if we
vote of all red we run over to all blue
and
that I was talking about Trump
where how did all of these people that
didn't you know
want him show up and all the people that
wanted him didn't show up the second
time
that's what I was saying so this person
said the answer is both
uh wait let me reread what I said uh on
Monday you were talking about the recent
U.S presidential
results and asked whether a bunch of red
people thought Trump had it in the bag
and didn't show up
um I don't think I said they thought he
had it in the back
who knows I can't remember what the [ __ ]
I said or did a bunch of blue people
show up who didn't in 2016. the answer
is both Trump had more than 11 million
additional voters in 2020 than in 2016
see tables below and Biden got more than
15 million additional voters than
Hillary did in 2016.
the sense oh so the problem was Hillary
right
the Census Bureau reported that 2020 was
the highest voter turnout of the 21st
century and that's because of trump dude
I mean that guy is [ __ ] PT Barnum
you know that guy brings the [ __ ]
eyeballs
um
uh however that's not the whole story
uh where there was a reduction was in
the number of Voters choosing a third
option oh you can do this whole [ __ ]
you're gonna blame
I still don't think it's bad to vote
third party I want to encourage more
[ __ ] people to
I don't know whatever
uh I'm just going to stay out of this uh
there were nearly five million fewer
voters casting ballots for a third
option in 2020 compared to 2016.
yeah people enough people just were like
I don't even give a [ __ ]
if we get
a warmonger with dementia
anything but Trump that's what ended up
happening
Donald Trump man that [ __ ] can
anybody wear out a welcome like that guy
my God
um I honestly I don't know if I said my
my opinion was what I thought happened
to that guy was
I don't think the people like
in corporations and in Banks really give
a [ __ ]
whether it's a Republican or
a Democrat what they want is consistency
okay they want to be able to anticipate
what this person is going to do so they
can protect their money
all right
and when you had a [ __ ] guy like
Trump who no one could predict what the
[ __ ] he was going to do
um
other than he was going to totally
surprise you I just feel like
I don't know I feel like they just got
him out of there
that kind of got him out of there
um
I don't know dude I'm [ __ ] cynical
dude I mean I literally think the
[ __ ] NFL has a side deal with Vegas
with these stupid [ __ ]
prevent defenses anyway obviously most
people who vote view the third party
vote as a throwaway with no real chance
for success
uh that's not what they're doing is
they're actually voting for the person
that they think is going to be the best
which is what everybody should be doing
instead of being blindly loyal to these
two stupid [ __ ] parties
all right and you would actually get
better candidates
and you'd have a third party [ __ ]
option
and stop making everything it's either
this or that and turn everything into
Hatfields and McCoys
um that's what I think I don't know I'm
crazy
um anyway but what if there was a choice
for an actual third option the null void
vote what do you think it's not a null
vote it's it's encouraging a third party
you guys are all just you're
institutionalized anyway what do you
think would happen if every ballot had a
no option and a candidate couldn't be
elected
when the null ballots exceeded a third
of the cast ballots
I don't know what I would think because
I don't understand that question let me
read this again obviously most people
who vote view the third party vote as a
throwaway
well yeah they do with no real chance
for success but what if there was a
choice
for an actual viable third option
the null vote
if he's saying it's a viable third
option but also saying it doesn't count
what do you think would happen if every
ballot had a no option
and a candidate couldn't be elected when
the null ballots
exceeded a third of the cast ballots it
would essentially be a referendum on the
candidates sending a message to the
parties to go back and find better
options
Food For Thought food for thought dude I
mean I don't know how smart you think I
am I don't even get that but that that
sounded like you found some sort of
solution in there
oh my god dude I had my [ __ ] head is
throbbing here guys uh let me just blow
through these last two these will be
quick answers
but the reading will still be as
excruciatingly long
girlfriend is a dreamer Daydream
Believer
homecoming queen
isn't it crazy how two beetles died
before two monkeys died
you know no monkeys had died right
there was two beetles were gone and
everybody in the monkeys was alive
you know they had a two to nothing lead
and then the monkeys came storming back
and three of them died
you know and now it's three to two
monkeys
all right
if Mickey Donald's goes that's the
[ __ ] game
who would have thought you know
who would have thought Mickey dollars by
the way one of my favorite all-time
[ __ ] comedians
I love them on that show man funny as
hell
um
all right girlfriend is a dreamer hey
Billy ball game huge fan can't wait for
old dads to come out I was well I
appreciate that man I'm gonna I'm gonna
listen I'm not gonna lie to you guys man
when that thing comes out I'm calling in
a favor I need you guys all to [ __ ]
see it wherever it's gonna be I need you
to go [ __ ] see this thing
um and you will not be disappointed this
movie's [ __ ] hilarious
and I need you to [ __ ] go check it
out all right
um
I'll keep you posted anyway
but thank you okay I got one person who
wants to see it I was wondering if you
still give advice since I haven't heard
much of that on the podcast lately
um
anyway if you do I wanted to ask about
my girlfriend I'm an engineering student
and will likely have a well-paying job
in the future
she did not go to college and has
recently began going only recreationally
to get a literature literature studies
degree hey this chick knows how to live
okay uh she told me the other night that
she wants to go to graduate school like
Oxford to study English and just be a
student
I didn't [ __ ] on a dream but I was just
sitting there thinking
where's this money going to come from
like what are you going to do to pay
that off
she's a very hard worker enjoys making
her own money but she also wants to be
an actress which scares me a little
because of how risky pursuing that is
it's not as risky as you think okay if I
can get acting work as a bald Ginger I
mean
there's work out there
anyway
she works as a server and makes about a
grand a week which isn't bad
it's unbelievable
she wishes a server she makes a thousand
bucks a week
but [ __ ] is expensive here in Long
Island
she's making four grand a month waiting
tables
says 1K a week I swear to God anyway we
have a family
uh I'd like it if she were also
contributing to our income oh if we have
a family I'd like it if she were also
contributing to our income
so I wasn't the only one treating our
kids to vacation or financing their
futures
she's always saying how she
is
to be rich when she is older
I think you would want to say once she's
always saying how she wants to be
quote Rich when she is older but I feel
she has her head in the clouds all the
time
this bothered me should I look for
someone else I love this girl and she's
super down to earth when it comes
disagreements and compromising and I
love that she is a nerd like me however
this has become a reoccurring worry for
me and I wonder how big a deal it seems
from someone more experienced
sorry for the long email thanks and go
make a pie crust
um
that's a tough one dude if that's
something that's bothering you
see this is one of the things where it's
not fair
you know it's not advantations to be a
guy in this situation
if it was a woman and she felt those
things you know
all of her girlfriend's like well you
need to sit down and talk to him about
that you know he's not gonna just be
[ __ ] staring at his navel while
you're out there busting your ass he's
got to [ __ ] bring some income home
um
but it's also like a dream so I mean
it's a hard thing
you know I would just kind of go into it
in a nice way and I would just ask her
like uh
you know try to see if she has some sort
of a plan
how you fit into it
and how it works
and if it seems batshit crazy
um
if it seems bad [ __ ] crazy it's probably
not going to happen to be honest with
you
I mean you really have to have a [ __ ]
plan
if you're going to make a dream come
true you got to go after it but you
can't just be going after it you got to
have some sort of a plan it's okay to
dive in and figure it out as you go but
you got to be like taking in information
and like
applying it like I didn't know [ __ ]
about stand up other than that I wanted
to do it so I signed up for a talent
contest I got into it and then I got
into it I started realizing
how the whole thing worked
and
then I started thinking about my age and
where I wanted to be and it do I need to
go to New York do I need to go to La I
checked out both places New York spoke
to me I went there I got to New York and
you just kind of do that
um
you know if you kind of [ __ ] like
want to do it
but you got like your head in the clouds
and [ __ ] like
I mean I don't know I don't know that's
a tough one dude
um
but you know something
it's a progressive time and like
there's this whole thing now talking
about equality and you know they earn
money too and you know some of them are
starting to pay alimony because they're
making more money than the guy when they
get divorced so
I mean I think your generation is it's
it's more like leveled out like
with my generation it wasn't like that
like I was sort of the last generation
was just like
you sort of expected to make the [ __ ]
money
um and pay for the date and all of that
[ __ ]
so I would sit down I would talk to her
about it
and uh you know because it's you you
know I know it's her dream but it's also
your life and you don't want to [ __ ]
start a family with somebody
um
you know that's going to be going after
this dream
doesn't really have a plan and you're
gonna have to [ __ ] support it and
move or whatever the hell you're gonna
have to do
yeah I would just
I would just in a nice way
you know
just sort of poke around and then
see if you feel like you can get into it
more deeper or something like that or
just say listen I don't know how to
approach this subject
but you know you know I want to support
you
these are these you know but I there's I
have a couple of concerns as far as like
how I fit into it so if you come at it
like that way then it's like you're not
saying like yeah you know if you [ __ ]
think you're gonna be out there you know
memorize the lines while I'm over here
[ __ ] digging ditches you don't do
that because then you just come off like
you're not supporting her
so just ask her how she plans on going
about it and how you fit into it
and then you know with that information
you can then decide if if you know this
is a situation you want to be in
um
I always you know
I don't know I can't say this but I just
always wonder when someone's with
somebody there I like her and everything
but she's saying that and it's kind of
making me feel this it's like
if you're really sort of Head Over Heels
you kind of look past [ __ ] like that but
if you stay with somebody long enough
maybe you start no I don't know
just do whatever the [ __ ] I said 30
seconds ago sorry my head's pounding
right now all right
um
all right moving from North Carolina to
New York LA or DC
okay
oh man [ __ ] the Carolina is out by
the Appalachian Mountains are just
incredible
um dear Billy insert cleveral
alliteration here
oh you tapped out
all right long time listener here
obviously I think you're funny as [ __ ]
your shit's funny sorry so keep it up
thank you I grew up in a small town of
less than 10 000 in eastern North
Carolina that's amazing
I was born in a small town it's a very
country area
most most never leave my hometown I
decided to do something drastically
different with my life I graduated from
school and I'm now practicing so-called
big law
no one in my family has ever done
anything close to this so I have no
guidance
I like are you stepping out there good
for you I know you're a comedian and not
a lawyer but you are well traveled and I
need some advice okay
um
my job has told me
that I I may have to move from North
Carolina to either D.C New York City or
La what advice would you give someone
moving from North Carolina
to either of those cities I'm 29 year
old male
with a noticeably beautiful bride who
will be joining me
all right so you got the hardest part
out of the way you got the person you
want to spend your life with that's
great the biggest city we've lived in is
Raleigh North Carolina Research Triangle
Raleigh North Carolina
got to go down with Daryl's on
Hillsborough Street uh but I know that
is nothing compared to these places
um
I'd appreciate your advice on this thank
you for your podcast I went through a
spell of substance abuse several years
ago and your mind set on drinking help
me switch my Outlook away from the court
ordered
AAA brainwash
you're doing more than comedy as always
go [ __ ] yourself but do so responsibly
so you can take care of your beautiful
family okay
all right dude
um
living in any of those cities
is not a [ __ ] problem
all right you know how to take care of
yourself you already have a job
and you already have your wife
okay
you know with your smartphone you can
find out where to shop
what it really is is it's like you know
how to do all of that stuff
it's no different what you really have
to do is it's your mindset
you got to be in the right mindset
in all of those places like as far as
everywhere you're going to go to La is
probably going to be
the biggest different thing see oh and
other side of the country different time
zone all of that stuff
I know you know DC DC still has a
southern Vibe New York City obviously
that's East Coast higher energy or
whatever
you'll be fine
the biggest thing is your attitude
the one thing I learned the first time I
lived in LA
was it wasn't the city it was me
and I came out here
and you know I had all these
preconceived notions about what Los
Angeles was
you know I was an insecure person so me
being from the East Coast was a big
thing for me and I had to wear my sports
gear and my [ __ ] three-quarter
leather jackets everybody knew that you
know hey man that guy's from the Mean
Streets of of the suburbs of the safe
suburbs of Boston Massachusetts you know
20 searching for some [ __ ] identity
right
um and it wasn't until I left la
then I thought and I discovered you know
years later coming back with more of an
open mind the incredible Cuisine the
hiking the outdoor activities the
museums and all of this incredible [ __ ]
that is it the culture the music
all of this stuff that is out here
um
and I would say the number one like
worst Travelers
that I've met are New Yorkers
people that grew up in New York it's
this weird
thing that they have or everywhere they
go they have to like [ __ ] on it
and um
I don't I think there's just too many
songs written about New York
ball washing that City like I don't know
what it is like um they go to other
cities and they count skyscrapers and
talk about when [ __ ] stays open until
and you can't get any good this year but
it's like dude
do you really think this place sucks and
everybody just sits here accepting that
it sucks it's like that's everywhere you
go there's fun to be had and it's going
to be different fun and it should be
different
it should be different you're going
someplace different the whole purpose of
travel
that's what's funny to me about New
Yorkers it's like I went I left New York
and I went to this other City
and it was [ __ ] different it's like
yeah
yes
that's what's supposed to happen
um
I went to Jacksonville Florida and had a
[ __ ] blast one time I was just like
oh my god what the [ __ ] am I gonna do
there and I tried alligator I went to a
[ __ ] gun range I shot guns with
[ __ ] silences on them I went to a
jaguars came I had a [ __ ] blast
I had a blast it's not a place I would
ever live but like when I think of
Jacksonville now though I have a happy
thought of going there now if I went
there and I tried to do la [ __ ] or
Massachusetts sitter in [ __ ] New York
[ __ ] I love New York City or whatever
but like
that would be my advice you're going to
do fine in all of those cities
just move there and have an open mind
and if your wife is a little nervous or
whatever just say listen you know we're
young
we don't have to stay here we're just
gonna you know I'm working my way up in
this firm whatever
if you want to go back to North Carolina
someday I have no problem with that all
right none of this [ __ ] is permanent
We're Young and what ends up happening
too is you live in a [ __ ] City
for a while in the with the wrong
mindset when you get pulled away
you know it's them when you think like
oh [ __ ] I could have done all this [ __ ]
when I was there and I didn't do it
because I was too busy hating on the
place so just keep an open mind you'll
be [ __ ] fine all right
anyway that's the podcast
go [ __ ] yourselves [ __ ] the prevent
defense
go Bruins and I will check in on you on
Thursday